ونلاقيه في الدرعيه وفورملون في جده
السعوديه واحده من دول قليله موجوده على
خريطه اهم سباقات لسيارات السرعه في
العالم
في جده تابعوني لاعطيكم خمسه فروق اساسيه
بين السباقين واحد فورميلا وان اكتم بكثير
انطلقت عام 1950 وتحظى باعلى نسبي مشاهده
لسباقات السيارات عالميه
السرعه القصوى لبعض
280 كيلو متر في الساعه لكن من حيث
دائما
فقط
ملون في المتوس الى اثنين فاصل سته ثانيه
للوصول الى نفس السرعه ثلاثه على المستوى
التقني سيراتو ملون كما هو معروف تعمل
بالوقود التقليدي لكنها باتت الان مختبر
مهم جدا لتطويل افضل انواع الوقود القليله
الانبعاثات والشركه ارامكو السعوديه
بالذات العبوا دورا كبيرا في هذا المجال
في المقابل بطوله
تنافسيه لتطويل وتجربه التقنيات الجديده
في مجالات الطاقه المتجدده وسيارات
الكهربائيه لكن الفريق الجوهري ان الجميع
سيارات في فورملائي لديها نفس الهيكل
والبطاريهم الاساسي في استراتيجيات الفرق
تتنافس في عدد مرات تغيير الاطارات وامل
الوقود وعدد الثواني التي يقضيها السائق
على وجود لهذا كله تبديل الاطارات هي خير
مسموح الا في حاله تعرضها
الاستراتيجيه تقوم على موازنه بين الشحن
واستهلاك الطاقه فزياده السرعه تعني زياده
استهلاك البطاريه اما استخدام المكابح
فيعيد شحن السياره
الذهاب الى منطقه اثار جورج ليحصل على
بوست ثم يعود الى الحلبه
16 سباقا حول العالم وكل سباق يمتد ل 45
دقيقه
سيكون اربعه منهم في الخليج هذا العام جده
وابو ظبي
عشاق الفراوله
فيردون بان الاهم بالنسبه اليهم انه سباق
[موسيقى]